hi everyone thanks for joining today
yeah so like you've heard you're still
in the vision track and in the next few
minutes we're going to be looking at
some known problems in Asian models
specifically adversarial examples and
actually you might have been already
seen this image going around for the
last few years it was very popular it's
taken from the young good fellow paper
from 2014 where he and his colleagues
explained how to perturb or attack an
image of a well several different images
in this case it was a panda which after
having some slight noise well
perturbation superimposed fooled a
neural network into thinking that it was
actually a given now in the next few
years there's been a lot of activity
whoops let me try to get this video
going and the same effect was taken to
real-life so if you take a look at the
video this is originally a 3d printed
turtle which without any kind of
perturbation is correctly identified as
a turtle
however this team a couple of years ago
was able to 3d print an adversarial
turtle that was systematically
identified as a rifle by an inception
model trained over imagenet and it
wasn't just a one-off angle it wasn't a
cherry-picked way of seeing the turtle
it was actually consistently no matter
what angle it was picture from now in
the next few minutes we're going to talk
about what these several examples are
whether you should be concerned and how
they affect you and if you want to use
them to your advantage how you can do so
so why am I actually interested in them
I'm a computer vision engineer by trade
my most of my background has been in
medical imaging but for the last couple
of years I've been working in autonomous
driving and
similar systems it's a miscibility so
medical imaging and autonomous systems
that's two fields where adversarial
examples are likely to have a huge
impact now what are they so I'm going to
dive into a couple more examples to also
that could affect mobility you can see
here an example where instead of adding
slight perturbations a team last year
was able to fool near networks in real
life by sticking certain fake pixels so
to speak on a stop signal for instance
making the classifications say it was a
40-mile I think it was a 40 mile per
hour signal now it's not just
classifiers you can also see the same
effect on detectors so this year at cvpr
another team was able to fool this is a
yellow v2 detector and by printing a
poster that was held in front of that
person they were able to bypass the
detector so if you think if you're
interested in privacy if you're
interested in surveillance systems this
is something you might want to look into
I think it's actually become already a
t-shirt if you if you take a look you'll
notice how as soon as the guy turns the
poster around he is again detected so
there you go he's now going to tell that
poster around and you'll see how Yolo
again sees him if he gives it to his
colleague then he is again detected but
his colleague isn't but it's not just
RGB actually and this I'm going to show
your video where you're going to see the
expected behavior and in lighter
you're going to notice how there is
there's a regular box placed in the
middle of the road and then the it will
be highlighted here as soon as it gets
detected so as you can see we do have a
box detected here and you'll see in a
minute what happens
the team places instead of this benign
box one that is adversarially generated
so you'll notice how there's a different
box being placed and in no case is is it
detected here now you can think about
the implications this might have in an
autonomous driving for instance but it's
not just that domain in healthcare this
year there's been a paper where they
they generated the same kind of other of
examples so again adding some
perturbation to the original image they
tried it with pneumothorax they tried it
with a melanoma
so the original the originally healthy
image was perturbed and they obtained
misdiagnosis of a melanoma and the mb
inverse also worked
so they took malignant images
superimposed some some perturbations
obtaining a diagnosis of a healthy case
now what what's going on here what's
happening the very simplified
explanation is if you have if you have a
classifier the goal is to have this
decision boundary that allows you to
tell whether a sample belongs to Class A
or Class B and what an attack is
actually doing is trying to force a
sample from Class A with the minimum
effort necessary so that it goes
squarely into the space that will make
it be classified as being Class B but
how do you do this actually one of the
simplest method to do this the first
where your method is very simple it's
very similar to how you train it on
networks so if you're familiar with them
if you've heard how the idea is you feed
a stack of images into your classifier
iteratively and you expect to have a
label at the end and when that label is
wrong then you take you will have a loss
that goes up you take the gradient of
that loss with respect to the weights
you've got propagate that because your
goal is to tweak those weights little by
little until that loss goes down again
and when it
does you consider your model trained now
the difference between this and an
attack is basically to one you want that
error to go up not down because you are
attacking a model and to that model
you're not training it it's frozen
you've already trained it you're
actually attacking a model that is that
already exists so you don't have access
to it and that's what this black model
in the middle represents you're not
going to be seeing that model but what
you will want to do is tweak the input
so what you do is you take that loss you
take the gradient with respect to the
input image and that's the so-called
noise that you're seeing and now all you
have to do is add that that noise or
that perturbation to the original image
and there you go now you've made
yourself an adversarial example that you
can throw at your at your model so what
kind of attacks are there it's not just
the first gradient method there's plenty
of them and you can look at them in a
let's say in two different dimensions
one of them being what you know about
your model the most the mildest attack
being the one where you know nothing
about the model you have no access to
the weights you have no access to the
original data not even the loss function
and on the other side of the spectrum
you would have an attack where you know
absolutely everything about the morning
you may you may even have access to that
to it and you can optimize your attack
over it and in somewhere in the middle
are attacks that he used proxy models to
to optimize another way of looking at
the attack at the attack is thinking
what the expected effect is the mildest
of them being one in which maybe you
just want to reduce the confidence of
the prediction so for instance for for
the case of privacy or surveillance
systems maybe it's just enough that the
detector doesn't see me with a high
confidence because usually in any
innovation system you're going to be
tweaking your we're going to have a
confidence threshold underneath anything
that falls below that confidence you
think well it's a false positive so we
don't show it so as soon as I've managed
to get a classifier or
to think that I'm a human but maybe with
just 20 percent confidence I'm probably
okay now the next level to that is where
you're not just reducing the confidence
but you want to have the wrong label
being in return so for instance that
case of the Panda and the Gibbon you
don't really care what the output label
is as long as it's the wrong one and
then an increased malignancy of an
attack would be where you're actually
forging label so let's say I'm trying to
forge documents or I'm trying to cause
chaos on the streets by making a
classifier systematically think that a
stop signal is actually a 40 mile per
hour signal so why is this happening and
the there's a there's bad news because
there's no consensus yet in academia so
from what I've seen there's a whole
bunch of literature supporting different
hypotheses many of them reasonable and
there is no consensus however there's
been one hypothesis published this year
which is I'm very excited about it
because one because of the implications
it has and two because it's also very
intuitive and it's by Andrew Ilyas and
colleagues who proposed that the reason
why this is happening is not because
neural networks are faulty or because
they're there's bugs they are actually
exposing features there are highly
correlated with the classes but it's
just that humans aren't picking up on
them we're not seeing them and the way
they explain this is well let's imagine
that or or actually there are some
features that are very obvious to humans
and so and you can perturb them to an
extent and humans will be able to see
the differences and there's other type
of features that are extremely subtle
and neural networks can see them but
humans cannot so some perturbations that
you add to those features will make the
neural network realize that a frog is no
longer a frog
whereas but the human will not realize
it so let's let's try this in the room
let's imagine so let's imagine that this
part of the
let's say this part of the room from
like from here to there you're humans
and you're only going to be able to see
the outline of this bunny and from here
to all over there let's assume that you
can see the full image you're going to
be in their own networks and you're
going to be able to see the texture the
colors absolutely everything about the
bunny okay so you folks can only see at
once when you see a bunny you see this
okay so can I get a show of hands who
thinks this is a bunny so sign it to
check oops okay so I'm focusing on the
humans here who thinks this is a bunny
okay confidence curly up that's good so
if I perturb that outline of the bunny I
can make all sorts of crazy things but
as long as I keep a rough shape of the
two fluffy ears and and the and the you
know the cheeks and everything I'm going
to suppose this is still a bunny but let
me check who thinks this is still a but
all of these are bunnies fairly
confident so I'm going to go back to the
other image and I'm going to perturb it
slightly so you are able to see
everything I'm not going to show it yet
but you're going to be able to see it
and you're going to see this is this
still a bunny now you're cheating oh no
you're not okay so you still think this
is a bunny when I show you the feature
that the humans aren't able to see is
this a bunny
no no hence went up now the humans were
seeing this and they were saying this is
a bunny the neural networks were able to
see the full thing and they're saying
hell no this is no bunny and that's the
that's the whole point of that paper
there are features that are really
correlated to the class over of a bunny
it's just that humans weren't able to
pick up on them so when you add
perturbations to them the neural
networks realized that the image has
changed too much for it to still be a
bunny or in this case of the paper a
frog it's now something completely
different
because that subtle feature has changed
anyway let's take a step back because so
this this is fun this is really
interesting and it's a great read read
but does it really affect us should we
be caring about this because most of the
time we're concerned about attacks about
hackers
and how fragile our systems are but
there's there's this saying that you
should never attributed to to malice
what it's just plain stupidity and when
I say stupidity I really mean well lack
of diversity lack of experience like
half time lack of money there's all
sorts of things you actually have to do
to get your systems up and running and
you don't always have all the means that
you need so for instance whenever you're
building a system you're going to want
to design your data collection correctly
you need to go out and annotate it
you're going to have to while you're
training design the correct the correct
augmentations you're going to have to
evaluate and test the hell out of your
model before you put it in production
and you cannot always do this properly
and in fact when you don't things go
things go wrong so there is been there's
been crushes there's been systems that
were biased against against certain
specific humans there's been I mean
there's all sorts of things that go
wrong and it wasn't malice it wasn't
hackers it was not versatile examples it
was lack of time lack of diversity lack
of lack of a lack of many things so what
I'm trying to say here is sure
adversarial examples are a problem
hackers in the future might be a problem
but the very first stop should be well
you need to robusta fie the basics of
your systems because that will make you
fall a lot faster than a hacker will in
any case let's say you're in a domain
where adversarial examples are already
an issue again this is a whole bunch of
things that you need to have covered and
let's say you design your data
collection correctly you've got all your
data you manage the annotations there's
two places where adversarial examples
can help one is during training where
you can
meant the training data so I suppose if
you're working ambition you're probably
already applying all sorts of
augmentations you're already flipping
your images changing intensity values
you're playing with contrast you're
adding noise probably well an
adversarial attack is only another form
of fix of augmentation you can apply why
not and then the way this would work is
you take it you take your vanilla
training set you put it through your
adversarial tool box you generate a
whole bunch of items are examples and
you feed them back into your classifier
or detector or whatever is your training
and at least your model will already
have been exposed to those adversarial
examples now this is this has the
advantage that you don't need to really
ask why the adversarial examples are
happening you can just go about it in
brute force you're throwing you're
giving your model a ton of address all
examples of etic trains and at least
it's it can learn from them but the
problem is how are you sure that you've
got everything covered you don't you
just don't you don't know when to stop
and you can't know when to put your
model in production now another way of
doing this and they're independent so
you can actually apply both of them is
you can stress test using adversarial
examples so the idea would be there's
there's tons of tools out there that
already have the latest attacks or you
can implement them on there on your own
and you would take your testing data
again put them here at becerril toolbox
and for and systematically for each
known attack generate examples so that
you can test your model and at least
report which attacks had what effect so
at the very least when you're trying to
certify a model or win at least trying
to report to to someone how good it is
you can tell hey we know we've
identified that it's weak against this
and this but it's perfectly robust
against this other thing and the way you
would do it is well this is an example
visit this again is my laptop and you
what you do is for each of those images
that you're going to throw at your model
you Jenner
adversarial example and you throw at it
and in this case while I was playing
with it it was originally identified as
a laptop with an 80% success of a
confidence sorry and then when a 300 a
perturbation that was supposed to be a
stole the result I had was that it was a
prayer rug for 40% confidence so at
least I can tell whoever asked me that
the inception model I was using to test
this on is weak against an NF GM attack
with in this kind of result but I would
suggest that we actually want to go one
step further and we want to interpret
these results because what I was asking
myself was well if the whole point of
this is that there features that I'm not
looking at what kind of what features
are contributing to the prediction of my
laptop when I have a healthy image like
in this case and what is the model
focusing on when I throw at it a
perturbed case and it's and the
difference is quite notable so in the
first case it's focusing on what it
should it's looking at the at the at the
laptop and it's looking at what I would
look at if I'm trying to identify it
right and in the case of the perturbed
image all that is completely lost and
it's actually looking somewhere else so
now you can understand why it's thinking
this was a prior rug now if you're
interested in playing with it yourself
I'm leaving here a list of tools that
are actually extremely handy they're all
Python based and there's also a bunch of
there's there's a ton of coops out there
if you want to to play around with it
some of them are framework specific but
in any case they're easy to get and
they're fairly intuitive basically you
just import the attack apply it on your
model and you can start playing around
with it in no time and in fact if what
you want to do is is tweak them this is
that the attack I was showing before the
first gradient method this is most of it
implemented in lesson 10 then 10 lines
of code so if you want to start around
with it yeah take a picture go there and
and have fun so to recap with
look at what adversarial samples are
we've taken a look at whether we should
care that much and in point being yes by
all means be aware that they exist be
aware that they will happen and be aware
that you might be affected but focus on
the basics first and we've seen a couple
of ways that you can apply the
adversarial examples too robust to fire
your models basically breaking them and
reporting how they were broken and then
exposing your models to them so that
they become a bit more robust so thank
you very much and if you've got any
questions shoot thank you I'll be taking
questions if anybody has any so in your
experience how much improvement you
actually get when training on
adversarial samples because I can
imagine for example in the first
gradients approach then there would
always be sort of another's hair
gradient even after training and others
hair samples right yeah something I
didn't quite mention but but it's really
important is there's a there's a factor
called why we call it epsilon and it's
been basically you when you generate you
don't just generate one single image out
of that perturbation you generate a
whole range of them and of course the
stronger that epsilon is the bigger it
is the more perturbation you're adding
the more obvious it is to the human that
the image has been tinkered with or
tampered with but of course the effect
is also much bigger in the in the model
something that has been shown is that
training on adversarial examples doesn't
protect you from other attacks though so
only applying the fuzz gradient method
and thinking you're good is definitely
not hire not not advisable you need to
cover all of the other attacks if you
really want to be a robust to them
is there a question over here no all
right well thank you very much for
sharing your information